[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 22 janvier
bienvenue pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv et 78 tout
de suite les titres de ce set 8 journal
140 patrons de multinationales au
château de versailles lille ont été
conviés par emmanuel macron pour un
sommet de l'attractivité à quelques
heures de l'ouverture du forum de davos
objectif montrer les atouts de la france
sur le plan économique
c'est officiel la france retire sa
candidature pour l'exposition
universelle 2025 décision qui concerne
un territoire paris saclay où auraient
pu se tenir l'événement et mais aussi sa
grande université dont le projet se
formalise gilles bloch président de
l'université paris saclay est notre
invité et puis le cri d'alarmé de
plusieurs habitants du square ifart
j'attrape plusieurs logements ils sont
insalubres vendredi une délégation
d'élus à visiter des lieux à l'appel de
l'association de défense des locataires
de la ville reportage google coca cola
facebook ou encore goldman sachs 140
patrons de multinationales au château de
versailles pour le sommet choose france
choisir la france le premier ministre
edouard philippe notamment à présenter
et vanter les évolutions de l'économie
française à ces chefs d'entreprise
le député de la première circonscription
des yvelines didier baichère a également
participé au déjeuner avec son voisin de
table le pdg de la bank of america
propos recueillis par nicolas landry on
a parlé beaucoup avec le ceo de bank of
america de financement également le
patron d'allianz donc nous ont posé
beaucoup de questions sur l'agilité en
france les réformes qu'on envisageait
par rapport à la fiscalité il avait bien
bien entendu les sujets de la flat tax
que n'avait mis en place et on a eu
aussi assez rapidement des questions sur
l'agilité du marché du travail sur notre
capacité à transformer les compétences d
des salariés donc j'avais pu expliquer
qu'on allait mettre 15 milliards sur la
table aujourd'hui pour développer notre
programme de formation professionnelle
et puis pour développer l'apprentissage
qui est une clé en fait du développement
des compétences de demain
je pense que c'est important de
représenter versailles de représenter 50
et en yvelines on a un territoire où il
ya énormément d'entreprises que moi à
titre personnel je rencontre très
régulièrement toutes les semaines et on
se fait très régulièrement l'écho j'ai
envie d'air en particulier des pme et
des tpe de la circonscription on à ce
sommet qui est en train de se conclure
par un dîner avec le président de la
république emmanuel macron ils pointent
les faiblesses structurelles du modèle
économique du projet le premier ministre
edouard philippe a officialisé le
retrait de la candidature de la france
pour l'exposition universelle 2025
à la fin d'un projet dont les prémices
remontent à sept ans pour rappel la
candidature avait été déposée
officiellement en septembre en cas
d'attribution de l'événement c'est le
territoire de paris saclay qui devait
recevoir le village global de l'expo
bonsoir gilles bloch dons soit la lettre
le président de l'université paris
saclay on va faire le point dans
quelques instants sur le projet ou en
est-on de cette grande université une
réaction déjà sur ce retrait de
candidature en tant que président de
paris saclay comment comment vous l'avez
vécu en bas c'est d'abord une surprise
c'est annoncer un dimanche matin je me
suis rallié à cette heure j'avais la
radio j'entends ça et puis une déception
parce que l'université paris saclay ces
établissements s'étaient engagés aux
côtés des collectivités aux côtés du gip
pour défendre c'est nettement d'intérêt
public voilà ce qu'on avait affaibli
qu'elle était pour défendre cette
candidature pour lui donner un contenu
le thème de l'exposition universelle la
connaissance partagée la planète à
protéger ça nous parlait énormément
c'est bon ça faisait appel aux voix là
école parfaitement en phase avec notre
identité et donc c'est une déception
parce que cette exposition universelle
si on l'avait obtenue face aux
concurrents internationaux
c'était un coup de projecteur
extraordinaire sur notre territoire 25 à
40 millions de visiteurs ça c'est est ce
que ta blait le petit exposé france 23
milliards d'euros de retombées
économiques pour cette université paris
saclay on voit on va en parler qui qui
va voir le jour si je puis dire ça sera
dans les années 2020 qui va le projet va
se formaliser vraiment dans les années
2020 quelles conséquences ça peut avoir
pour pour cette université pour nous
c'était un gain de notoriété énorme on
est déjà une université qui existe on y
reviendra
c'est pas juste un projet mais avoir des
millions des dizaines de millions de
visiteurs qui auront été en contact avec
ce territoire qui auront vu les
bâtiments universitaires qui auront vu
des des personnels des étudiants
mobilisés sur certaines activités de
l'exposition universelle ça aurait été
un gain de notoriété énorme au moment où
on lance cette cette université alors de
nombreux élus bien sûr se sont exprimés
sur ce retrait de la candidature je vous
propose d'écouter tout de suite est la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse invitée de nos
confrères de rtl et lci dans le grand
jury que c'est une décision qui est
précipitée soudaine et qui évidemment
m'inquiète elle m'inquiète non seulement
pour l'exposition universelle qui aurait
été une très belle vitrine
vous savez que le thème c'était les
savoirs et l'environnement qu'elle
devait se dérouler à saclay qui a
vocation à devenir le moteur
technologique de la france
donc c'était quand même un très bel
événement de rayonnement de ce que la
france a de plus beau mais ça m'inquiète
plus durablement
parce que je ne voudrais pas à la suite
de la décision sur notre dame des landes
cette expédition sur l'exposition
universelle je ne voudrais pas que
finalement l'état recul sur tous les
grands projets d'investissements
structurants du pays
inquiétude valérie pécresse donc sur
d'autres projets structurants on pense
forcément quand elle dit ça à la au
grand paris express qui doit arriver sur
le territoire par sa ligne 18 500 en
2024 l'ami des transports elisabeth
bornes la semaine dernière a fait des
annonces est là confiants mais le tracé
mais évoque des possibles
allongement de calendrier est-ce que
vous avez vous une crainte aussi sur sur
l'arrivée de la ligne 18 après cet
abandon de l'expo universelle est ce que
vous avez des craintes sur la ligne 18
seulement on entend des signaux négatifs
depuis quelques mois des doutes sur un
projet qui a été validé revalider par
plusieurs gouvernements successifs qui a
été annoncé dans ses prémices en 2010
avec un calendrier où aujourd'hui on
devrait déjà roulé en métro sur le
plateau et cette ligne 18 c'est vraiment
l'épiné dorsale du système de transport
modernes dont on a besoin sur le plateau
de saclay on a cinq écoles une faculté
de pharmacie qui ont déménagé ou vend
des ménages et des dizaines de milliers
d'étudiants de personnel de familles qui
vont vivre dans cette ville campus qu'on
est en train de densifier et donc voir
ce projet de lisser dans le temps ou
voir remis en question moi j'attends
vraiment la parole gouvernementale pour
confirmer le projet est confirmé
l'échéance
ça nous inquiète énormément on est au
delà d'inquiétude on est vraiment dans
l'angoissé depuis quelques semaines mais
un calendrier retoqué devraient être
communiqués dans les prochaines semaines
je précise d'ailleurs avec le
l'universitaire avait lancé à ce sujet a
lancé une pétition pour le l'arrivée de
l'année 18 c'est ce demi dès 2024
donc les annonces ces différentes
annonces qui interviennent au moment
même où le projet alors le projet qui
est déjà formalisé mais on va dire qui
rentre dans le concret pour l'université
paris saclay je rappelle juste qu'en
en fin d'année dernière emmanuel macron
a annoncé que le territoire ce cendres
est autour de deux pôles d'excellence
l'un constitué justement par
l'université paris saclay avec les
universités je le rappelle paris sud
evry versailles saint quentin en
yvelines les écoles centrale supélec le
nsrs paris saclay et l'ex supoptique
l'actualité c'est que en décembre
l'université paris saclay a déposé son
rapport d'évaluation pour l'idex ça veut
dire initiatives d'excellence
concrètement ça apporterait quoi d'avoir
cette idex pour paris saclay alors je le
disais le projet c'est plus qu'un projet
c'est déjà une transformation qui est en
marche on diplômes des doctorants ont
diplômes des masses terriens depuis déjà
deux ans et c'est pas des petites
quantités c'est des milliers chaque
année on a un dispositif de recherche
qui est en train de se restructurer sous
l'égide de l'université paris saclay et
donc on bénéficie déjà depuis cinq ans
du financement de l'initiative
d'excellence
l'enjeu c'est de maintenir su très bien
soin de maintenir ce label est de
franchir une étape de plus dans la
transformation institutionnelle qui est
demandée pour s'aligner vraiment sur les
modèles internationaux de grandes
universités et pour continuer à
bénéficier de ce label et de ce soutien
dont on a vraiment besoin dans ces
périodes de j'étais attendu daïra jury
international qui va bien un jury
international qui s'est déjà réunie
plusieurs fois qu'on a rencontrés pour
une évaluation intermédiaire il ya deux
ans qui va nous auditionnés à nouveau en
février et en mars pour recommander au
gouvernement une décision sur la
gouvernance de cette université
par exemple et quelle place occupe les
les différentes universités les écoles
le
le modèle c'est vraiment un modèle de
transformation où on va d'une part
versée l'université paris sud et 2020 à
l'intérieur de l'université paris 7
accords l'université paris-sud
disparaître il ya quatre écoles qui
garderont une identité intérieure mais
qui seront aussi dans l'université paris
saclay vous avez oublié agroparistech
qui fait partie de mon morceau qui fait
partie de cette première phase de
transformation et donc tous ces acteurs
avec les sept organismes de recherche
qui nous accompagnent se sont mis
d'accord pour adopter un mot un nouveau
modèle de gouvernance avec un équilibre
absolument parfait entre élus et nommés
dans le conseil d'administration avec
des relations internes entre la
gouvernance de tête et les composantes
ou les écoles des relations de
subsidiarité de délégations beaucoup
plus poussé pour gagner en efficacité
donc tout ça a été décrit dans un
document politique qu'on a stabilisé au
mois de novembre et trace vraiment
maintenant une feuille de route crédible
et quel est le calendrier justement pour
avoir au 1er janvier 2020
un nouvel établissement qui donc inclura
les composantes issues de paris-sud
inclura les écoles qu'on a mentionné et
dans cette université les deux
universités de versailles et saint
quentin et d'evry seront partenaires et
auront vocation elle aussi à disparaître
et à devenir des composantes internes de
l'université à l'horizon 2025 si on peut
aller plus vite tant mieux mais c'est
une transformation d'une telle ampleur
on parle quand même toujours de 65 mille
étudiants de 15 mille enseignants
chercheurs et chercheurs autant de
personnel donc on est sur une
transformation qui doit se faire à
l'échelle d'une décennie allez je
précise que vous pouvez retrouvez toute
l'actualité de l'université paris saclay
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci j'ai le bloc
d'avoir une version président de
l'université paris saclay ça a été
lancée aujourd'hui parcours super c'est
le nom de la nouvelle plateforme pour
permettre aux lycéens s'inscrire pour
leurs études chaque année par exemple à
saint quentin en yvelines
plus de dix huit mille étudiants sont
accueillis et de nombreux élèves étaient
ce week-end au salon de l'étudiant à
versailles pour leurs recherches sujet
de camille lambert et nicolas
kirillovitch nouveauté cette année pour
les lycéens parcours suprend place à pbd
ce 22 janvier les élèves doivent
maintenant formulé dit veut mais sans
les hiérarchiser comme avant au salon de
l'étudiant de versailles ces changements
ne sont pas encore tout à fait clair
pour certains la réponse est fait c'est
décider rapidement et assez tardivement
et
effectivement les jeunes sont inquiets
on peut tout à fait le comprendre les
parents s'inquiètent beaucoup de la
procédure préalable c'est à dire de
l'inscription comment est ce qu'on fait
pour s'inscrire
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
choisir les voeux avant mais il ne
s'inquiète relativement peu de la
procédure après quand ils auront la
réponse une nouvelle plateforme censée
simplifier les démarches
le salon de l'étudiant de versailles
accompagne les lycéens dans leurs
recherches ils peuvent aussi compter sur
leur établissement pour être rassurés tu
as une initiation à part cour suprême va
s'inscrire avec les professeurs on a d
accompagnement personnalisé réservé à
l'orientation à la préservation des
écoles à la présentation de parcours sup
pour qu'on puisse apprendre et connaître
mieux la plateforme dans son ensemble
c'est un cas forcé mort un peu après je
vais essayer de faire de tout faire pour
les futurs étudiants ont jusqu'au 13
mars pour saisir leurs voeux sur
parcours sup peut être de nouveaux
arrivants fleurons les bancs des écoles
et universités de saint quentin en
yvelines
chaque année l'agglomération accueille
plus de 18 mille étudiants on continue
de parler études supérieures dans ce
journal avec une branche en particulier
c'est la communication bonsoir mathilde
obino bonsoir vous êtes duchesnay
originaire du chesnay vous cocu blier
haché studyrama concours d'entrée en
école de communication tous les bons
conseils exercices de préparation pour
préparer ces concours avant qu'on parle
de ce livre des gens peut être un mot
sur votre parcours vous êtes
communiquant de vous travaillez
notamment dans une entreprise
spécialisée dans numérique vous
enseignez à la communication dans
plusieurs écoles et comme finalement les
futurs élèves de ces écoles vous avez
fait votre formation au sein d'une école
de communication qui est elle celle d'un
oui oui après une formation en prépa
littéraire cuit en infocom assas j'étais
au celsa pour master 2 voilà pour
confirmer cette appétence pour la
communication c'est ça qui est l'école
de l'université paris-sorbonne
s'envolèrent dis pas de bêtises a servi
qu à voir si particulier ou à voir dans
un instant d'ailleurs un qui a plusieurs
écoles plusieurs formations pour faire
de la communication
vous êtes donc passer par cette fameuse
case concours qui peut prêter à quelques
peurs il faut le dire pourquoi avoir eu
envie de transmettre cette expérience se
savoir
alors avec la rade sur b qui a co écrit
ce livre avec moi nous sommes toutes les
deux anciennes élèves de prépa et aussi
du celsa ayant trouvé que c'était
intéressant de nos dénoue conseil en
tant qu ancien élève
nous avons aussi été confronté à l'écrit
à l'oral et du coup c'était à la fois de
livrer des conseils très formel sur la
dissertation sur les différentes
épreuves écrites et puis aussi comment
s'y préparer les trucs et astuces qu'on
nous donne pas forcément
et voilà c'est notre expérience dans ces
élèves aussi qui est présent dans cet
ouvrage selon vous quelles sont les
qualités d'un bon communicant un
communicant il va être curieux
absolument il doit pas se contenter de
ce qui est edward envie d'en savoir plus
d'approfondir son sujet est aussi va
être au courant de ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité culturelle et ne pas du tout
se rester enfermé dans l'univers la
communication il doit être force de
proposition aller vers les gens et ça
c'est quelque chose d'important et aussi
à d'être rigoureux voilà une fois qu'on
a collecté l'information ce qui est
important c'est d'être rigoureux pour
essayer de saisir au mieux les canaux
pour diffuser l'information et est ce
que ce monde de la communication
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils embauchent
voilà est-ce qu'il ya des postes au
sortir des études alors la communication
c'est un monde très concurrentiel il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de candidats mais ce
qui est important c'est de voir les
différentes parties ajustements qui
recrute le numérique ça c'est très
important avec tous ces métiers qui sont
conviés à cet univers
et puis aussi on revient beaucoup sur la
dimension du contenu pour faire passer
un beau message ça c'est important et
les entreprises reviennent de plus en
plus sur ses dimensions là donc ça ça
peut être une voie aussi à prendre mais
j'ai un mois différents métiers
aujourd'hui pour faire de la
communication il ya différents en
différentes possibilités
oui oui du community management aux
relations publiques
voilà avec des mimes des métiers qui
sont multiples et ça c'est intéressant
justement en allant rencontrer les
entreprises le monde des agences d'aller
voir un peu le profil qui nous intéresse
le plus c'est pour ça les stages les
alternances ce sont des bons moments
pour essayer de se confronter ces
métiers là et vous le disiez un petit
peu tout à l'heure je sur le numérique
la nouvelles possibilités qui s'ouvrent
aujourd'hui 2
nouveaux métiers nouveaux parcours
peut-être oui ça peut être très
intéressant justement d'allier à la fois
le numérique et ce qui se passe irréel
life et ça c'est très important de ne
pas rester cantonné juste un univers
mais pour saisir au mieux aller ensemble
et des parties prenantes
alors quand on est un jeune étudiant
qu'on veut faire de la communication
quels sont les différents cursus école
qui s'offre à nous aujourd'hui pour
faire de la communication
alors il ya un panel d'école connu je
pense au celsa l'efap l'iscom l'iacp à
l'iseg voilà des écoles qui sont
reconnus auquel on peut rentrer alors à
différents niveaux au niveau bac + 2 bac
+ 3 quant à +5 et puis ensuite une fois
adultes une fois après avoir suivi une
carrière professionnelle on peut y
rentrer aussi donc ça c'est intéressant
de voir ces formations-là à l'université
aussi donc ça c'est important de bien
prendre le temps de se renseigner
d'aller aux portes ouvertes
régulièrement justement pour se tenir au
courant des nouveautés
et puis doit être de contacter des
anciens élèves pour avoir leur retour
sur la question de l'insertion aussi
c'est important
toutes ces écoles dont parlait sont sur
paris ces formations ou sur toute la
france alors beaucoup sont sur paris
mais vous en avez aussi dans d'autres
villes de france donc ça c'est important
aussi de regarder par rapport à ce qui
se passe près de chez vous ils vous avez
aussi des bts dut de communication en
région dont on y accepte toujours par
concours ou des fois enfin c'est sans
concours 7 c'est toujours par concours
les écoles de communication les
formations en communication
alors après ça dépend si c'est à
l'université du coup là c'est une voie
plus traditionnelle voilà ça va vraiment
dépendre donc ça c'est important aussi
dans son souhait de faire une école de
communication d'anticiper en amont
plusieurs mois à l'avancé pour regarder
les voies d'entrée puis par fondement
des documents spécifiques
donc ça c'est important délai de
motivation pour anticiper pas la veille
commencé à être très dur pour
appréhender au mieux ces concours pour
les écoles de communication tél
finalement quel concept
cléon doit avoir en tête avant de avant
de franchir ces concours de passer ces
concours basse et revenir un peu sur la
communication la communication l'a
beaucoup associé au monde des paillettes
cet univers yards et je pense que c'est
important de revenir au fond c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est pas communiquer pour
communiquer dans le vide on perdrait en
efficacité
ça serait totalement diluée comme propos
mais voilà essayer de bien se rappeler
pourquoi quel est notre finalité quel
public on vise donc ça c'est important
de revenir vraiment fondamentaux les
raisons mêmes de la communication alors
dans le contenu je lis bien sûr
description il ya de la description des
métiers présentation des écoles il ya
aussi des conseils méthodologiques
forcément pour préparer au mieux
notamment les épreuves écrites il ya des
épreuves orales on valoir dans un
instant ça ressemble à quoi
un concours d'entrée en école de
communication par exemple le celsa parle
par lequel vous êtes passé ça ça
ressemble à quoi
alors on a de temps on à l'écrit et
l'oral l'écrit on va avoir une épreuve
d'anglais
ça se prépare évidemment et puis aussi
une épreuve de dissertation sur un sujet
donné donc là faut faire appel à ses
connaissances à sac ordures général donc
ça c'est ça c'est vraiment important et
puis rester dans le sujet éviter leur
sujet donc bien être sensible aux grains
des mots ça c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on insiste aussi et puis l oral
qui se prépare donc ça c'est prejean
pourtant du coup si on veut faire de la
communication j'imagine le rôle oui donc
de montrer à la fois la cohérence dans
son parcours sa motivation aussi pour
rejoindre l'école et puis sont suivis
pour pour l'école voilà pour l'intérêt
qu'est-ce qu'on apportera à cette école
et on devient par exemple sur le mode
molière initié par françois de wazières
justement cette initiative la voilà
comme les concours sont joints ans ça
donne une actualité donc ici et montrer
si on s'intéresse à la littérature qu'on
connaît les grands prix pour le cinéma
pareil le voile a essayé quand on rentre
dans un domaine de bien connaître ça
c'est important
et je précise également qu'il a
retrouvée dans ce livre bien sur
plusieurs sujets d'annales récent merci
mathilde obino d'avoir été avec nous
merci je rappelle vous êtes chez les
hyènes et vous co-publié donc chez
studyrama pardon le livre concours
d'entrée en école de communication tous
les bons conseils exercices de
préparation pour être bien réussir ses
concours et vous pouvez retrouver le
livre sur le site internet qui s'affiche
bas de l'écran dans l'actualité du jour
une quinzaine de députés en visite dans
les commissariats et gendarmeries de
france initiative de la commission des
lois
sa présidente la députée et les ruelles
de la 5e circonscription des yvelines
yaël brawn peavey s'est elle rendue au
commissariat de trappes le but échanger
avec les forces de l'ordre en vue de la
préparation de la loi sur la loi sur
j'ai perdu le mot est la voie la loi
donc sur la réforme de la procédure
pénale par d'euros et donc voilà ces
déplacements se feront dans ce but la
rattrape toujours l'association de
défense des locataires a reçu à vendredi
une délégation d'élus du conseil
régional et du département
elle a visité des logements insalubres
du square yves farge et les habitants
s'inquiètent du problème de
l'insalubrité qui concernerait attrape
4200 logement un reportage de nicolas
landry c'est l'humidité qu'elle nous
envahie d'un autre par thomas et on
n'arrive même pas à dormir surtout quand
il ya là plus ce père de famille vit
dans cet appartement avec sa femme et
ses enfants depuis un an un logement
insalubre plusieurs dégradations et de
l'humidité
une situation difficile accentuée par la
maladie de sa fille atteinte d'un cancer
nous ne pouvons pas laisser une
situation comme celle là alors avec
othman nasro autour de valérie pécresse
au sein de la région nous allons agir
nous allons mettre la pression
grâce à l'association de locataires pour
dire que nous ne pouvons plus financer
des bailleurs avec des subventions
publiques
s'ils ne font pas leur travail minimum
évidemment l'agglomération je crois à
l'intention de continuer elle aussi a
joué son rôle qui est de faire pression
sur un bailleur pour qu'il respecte ses
obligations légales et c'est triste
qu'on les besoins aujourd'hui on vient
de visiter une famille qui attend depuis
un an les travaux d'entretien ce cas
n'est pas isolé selon l'association de
défense des locataires 4200 logements
seraient touchés par l'insalubrité
attrape une situation présentée aux élus
du territoire dans les bureaux de
l'association
on a des problèmes aux tirs de deux
chauffards
d'hygiène de sécurité aussi mais pas à
pas pas de vos points de vue des
locataires c'est à dire c'est vraiment
les obligations du du bailleur qui sont
pas effectués du côté du bailleur social
valophis n'a pas donné suite à notre
demande d'interview
la société affirme que le dossier est en
cours de traitement à coignières
plusieurs projets intercommunaux avons à
fleurir cette année c'est ce qui ressort
du discours du maire jean-pierre
sevestre à lors de la cérémonie des
voeux de la ville vendredi au salon
saint-exupéry un centre aquatique commun
avec maurepas et l'encours est aussi une
police pluri communal dans un premier
temps avec nos repas composé de 15 à
jeun quand la police va se mettre en
place dès le mois de février dès le mois
de février effectivement nous avons en
phase de recrutement nous avons déjà
recruté plusieurs agents qui vont
permettre avec l'équipe existante de
maurepas de constituer une entité
maurepas coignières et permettre d'avoir
des créneaux et des possibilités d'être
sur place d'être visible beaucoup plus
fréquemment que ce qui était possible
par une entité d'une seule ville et
cette police intercommunale intégrera
également par la suite la ville
d'elancourt au total elle comptera avec
40 agents est là derrière aussi présenté
ses voeux vendredi à ses habitants
cérémonie qui se tenait à la salle du
scarabée la rénovation urbaine du
quartier du bois de l'étang sera à l'un
des grands chantiers en 2018 la ville
qui fait également 30 ans de jumelage
avec panique allait commune italienne
située dans la région de l'ombrie son
maire giulio kalubi n'y étaient présents
vendredi un jumelage qui lui tient à
coeur
écoutez ses propos au micro de nicolas
bary importante
il m'emmène teese est important parce
qu'on sait tant historique où il ya ceux
qui construisent des murs et insiste sur
la nécessité d'avoir des frontières les
échanges culturels les échanges d'idées
et de savoir pour le développement et le
lien de nos communes et la meilleure des
réponses à donner
taminiaux on a eu tout un tas de
deux manifestations des changes aussi
bien au niveau culturel que sportif
c'est plus du tiers d'une vie c'est
plein plein plein des choses et
maintenant on part aux services
bancaires
et puis pour refermer ce journal du
sport avec la reprise ce week-end de la
saison de football américain les
templiers d'elancourt jouer la première
journée du championnat de deuxième
division pour leurs débuts les élans
courtois n ont pu faire mieux que match
nul à domicile contre les vikings de
villeneuve d'ascq et des conditions
climatiques compliquées
nicolas kirillovitch et mickaël landreau
premier coup de sonde de la saison pour
le directeur sportif des templiers
d'elancourt frederick henderson ses
joueurs l'ont pas réussi à remporter ce
samedi 20 janvier leur premier match de
la saison de 2e division contre les
vikings de villeneuve d'ascq score final
8 partout fait beaucoup trop d'erreurs
au final des erreurs d'exécution des
erreurs qu'on a parce qu'on n'a pas
commise sur les matches de préparation
et qu'on retrouve ici alors que c'était
les mêmes types de défense qu'on avait à
affronter
on s'attendait pas à ce résultat la sera
qu'on s'attendait à mener très
rapidement dans la gamme principale
raison invoquée pour expliquer ces
erreurs techniques et conditions
climatiques difficiles la pluie tombée
pendant toute la rencontre sur le
complexe sportif europe
on a dû changer un peu notamment sur les
coups de pied de dégagement par exemple
on a jusqu'à aligner échanger stratégie
à cause du vent et puis de la pluie on a
vu que les coups de pied d'engagement il
portait beaucoup moins loin que
d'habitude s'il fait que les returner il
n'avait pas forcément chercher les
ballons très vite c'est vrai qu'on s'est
mis en danger de trois fois sur des
erreurs bêtes
annoncé comme l'un des favoris à la
montée avant la rencontre et l'encours
se retrouve dans le milieu de classement
de la poule 2 avec ce match nul
une situation qui n'inquiète pas le
staff le potentiel est toujours là on
est toujours mieux que l'année dernière
par contre le potentiel si on n'arrive
pas à le concrétiser sur le terrain ça
se transformera pas en victoire et on
attendra par nos objectifs donc bien sûr
je suis optimiste vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils
sont capables de produire la vérité du
terrain c'est celle du match et le
tableau de score il en a rien à faire de
sk s'entraîner six
c'est quand moi si on performe pas
jusqu'en sont pas là on gagne pas la
séance de rattrapage est programmée ce
dimanche 28 janvier sur le terrain des
diables rouges de villepinte une équipe
qui s'est inclinée lors de son premier
match de la saison
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
bonne soirée et excellente semaine à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]